do you guys want to see another movie
where Jennifer Lawrence is suffering oh
well you should go watch red sparrows
it's just break this down into our
reasons to see and reasons not to see
movie review format on the real rejects
only reason to see this movie the
performances are good Jennifer Lawrence
does a really good job with what she's
given her accent is I have to go away
for a while I'll be able to take care of
us no thank you
you know it's Jennifer Lawrence and if
you're gonna give her a role where she's
suffering she's gonna do a great job is
this what she does best is suffer yeah
she's great at selling that and hey joel
edgerton he's used to be pretty good too
and he's easily likable charismatic he's
probably the the lightest character in
this whole really the only good guy in
the whole movie yeah he's probably the
only character the movie doesn't make it
abundantly clear sucks he's the only non
creepy dude and him and Jennifer
Lawrence they work well together
although I mean the trailer shows you
they're supposed to have like sexual
romantic chemistry so whenever they're
not doing that they're really good
together but when that stuff happens I'm
like what that's not the chemistry I've
been feeling they do a good job and
there's other performers in here that do
a good job the cast the cast does good
Jeremy Irons and Kieran Foy Hinds Ciaran
Hinds - sleeve let's move on to the
reasons not to see this movie reason not
to see it it's just it's soulless if
you're one of those viewers who was like
Greg and Johnston like they like
everything that we don't like we've ever
been so synchronised like so soon yeah
there was a point where we looked over
and I think you said you know like I
kinda hate it yeah I think that's the
best way to describe it is as I kind of
hate the movie I wouldn't say I
passionately hate it it's just a movie
that gave me nothing to care about
whatsoever I don't like to hate it but I
kind of hate it yeah well at least to me
there's something at the core of this
movie I just find sort of repelling like
it never brought me in or made me yeah
next
too much of anything I mean we're gonna
talk about some subject matters that are
for sure gonna get this video not
suitable for advertisers I'm being slap
a trigger warning on this yeah yeah yeah
cuz there are some some pretty heavy
moments first off before going into some
of the heavy stuff and technical things
I think the editing is really poorly
done in this movie it's like 2 hours and
20 minutes and and there's so many
scenes in the movie he feels like it's
about 2 hours and 20 minutes feels it
goes on for way too long what I found
weird is the director of Francis
Lawrence seemed like whenever it was
dialogue scenes he didn't really give
two shits about that if there was
violence or sexual assault he really
took his time with doing that seduction
which there are a couple anything sexual
wise or violent wise that's what it
seemed like as he LC went into letting
this scene play out really letting this
moment be felt but most of the movie is
not sexual so there's a lot of it but
it's not most of the movie and most of
the movie is not violence and action
sequences similar in a way to atomic
blonde the way you thought that was
gonna be kind of a cool extravaganza and
then it turns out to be a lot more
deliberately passed and a lot more base
on his espionage plot this movie kind of
does a similar thing to that except you
could give two shits about whatever the
hell you're watching beyond baseline
human empathy
you know before going into this movie
for a couple days now I've actually been
doing a lot of reading up the cliche
trope that a lot of female characters
are given and I read a lot a lot of
stuff lately it seems like to make a
strong female character they usually
have to be raped in order for to make
them strong it's like I'm tough you'll
see a movie like John wick where his
life is stripped away from him his dog
dies he gets beaten but he's not
sexually assaulted but then I started
thinking about like that's true most
badass female characters in film and TV
shows get raped and it's used as a cheap
plot device to get you to go like oh
yeah this here become strong
that was what will push her over the
edge yeah becoming extraordinary in her
field yeah and the crap part is the most
of the time these movies are done by
dudes and this is a perfect example oh
this is how a guy handles a woman
getting raped and making it a plot point
that we're supposed to give a [ __ ] of
how yeah I gotta say like you know and
it's not the reason I hate the movie no
because there's so many other reasons I
like this movie beyond the way they
handle that and I mean truth be told it
it sounded at least going in it sounded
like there would be more of that kind of
thing in this movie but yeah just as a
device I feel like you know not to say
that the men cannot address and utilize
rape in stories but I think you kind of
owe it to everybody to at least consult
some women maybe have like a woman on
the screenplay at least or something
like as the books by a dude the
screenplays by a dude is directed by a
dude and they said like they gave
Jennifer Lawrence control over like how
the nude scenes were done and how you
know like she got to sign off on final
cut but like most of this movie feels
like yeah like dudes probably crafted
this yeah
the first act of this film I thought I
might actually be enjoying this film it
starts off with this plot of a girl who
is a famous ballerina Russia she's
Russian and she wants to take care of
her mom and then she's first shot is
gored it's just her doing a ballet yeah
it looks like a Jennifer Lawrence
trained for that and then she suffers a
terrible injury which leads to her you
know cuz her uncle works in the Russian
government through a series of events
she ends up becoming a thing called a
red Sparrow
which is a Russian spy whose main thing
is just seduction subduction and
extraction of information and honestly
early on in this movie you know a minor
spoiler for you guys it's in the first
act as part of the set up Jennifer
Lawrence's character gets raped when
that happened it's disturbing it was
everything after that moment of how I
saw they were handling it that oh
they're not even gonna like address it
they're not gonna yeah they're gonna use
this as a plot point to get us somewhere
but they're not gonna dive into the
psychological reactions of this hardly
because it's so it's out it starts off
like oh it's probably gonna be a
psychological study of this woman who
did not have any intentions of becoming
a spy and then now becomes a spy has to
learn about
duction and yada yada yada and then she
ends up going to this like Academy for
red sparrows which should just be called
rape Academy or rape school because
that's all it is they make a reference
let's try to dumb it down if you send me
to [ __ ] school but no it's it's just
rape take off your clothes
they do kind of call back in that scene
and make it focal yeah it does sort of
feel like the point is you're just gonna
have to do some stuff you don't like get
you yeah I get it as a device for this
movie but it doesn't utilize or explore
it well enough to really justify exactly
I hated how they handle it afters I'm
like oh they're just can't if you looked
at you I'm like oh there's not gonna
talk about that because at first I was
thinking okay there's gonna be a big
part of her character yeah as much as I
don't really care for this trope anymore
maybe I could still get onboard with
this movie but then they can it and then
it got me thinking like ten minutes
later there was really no point for that
rape scene she didn't need to get raped
in that scene there was no point for
that actually yeah the best you can say
is that it arguably justifies a later
scene which is arguably one of the most
effective moments this movie tries to
draw using all the elements that it's
pitched to you this sort of dark sexual
violent thing assume where the teacher
in the classes is pressuring is not
pressuring is just instructing her to
basically have sex with a guy in front
of the class when I had the scene plays
out that was an effective scene because
of the choice she makes there that
actually proved that her character is
pretty sharp been pretty resources but
this movie is kind of mean-spirited it
has no soul to it it's it's kind of it's
dull none of the dialogue scenes ever
land because they don't take time to
just let the dialogue scenes land in
like character moments land like the
dialogue itself is fine it's just
nothing really feels the way that edited
yeah and it doesn't feel like there's
much motivation for you just don't feel
for any of the characters or get much
for their inner life at all so you're
left with this plot that just keeps
moving and you keep wondering is she
gonna you know stick through the to the
rushes are you gonna you know double
agent it up and go someplace else
it didn't really do that either because
the trailer has you thinking like which
side is she gonna be on but the movie
kinda just was it does the movie doesn't
leave anything the mystery they kind of
just show you oh here's going on with
joel edgerton here's what's going on
with Jennifer Lawrence oh here's where
they are there's no questions and then
by the time they get to the finale which
suddenly starts having like twists and
reveals I really sitting there going
like wow I just don't give a [ __ ]
yeah with nothing else to latch on to
you're just sort of left with this
feeling of like what is this all for
like what's the point like why are we
here
who's this movie who is this before yeah
yeah because it's not stylistic it's not
cool it's like one could argue that it
looks pretty at times I was telling John
the car think it only looks pretty
because of where they shot it it's not
pretty because of this stylistic way
they did the cinematography it's one of
those movies where you're I'm like this
is another unnecessary IMAX experience I
like an ugly or a cold movie sometimes
there's something in this particular
film that there's no personalities yeah
no personality the Devil's Rejects is an
ugly cold movie but there's a
personality about it that grinds it in
which makes it enjoyable is just bland
like it's fast paced but it's also
plodding at the same time it doesn't
have any one unique flavor other than
pain and cold that's the other thing
it's it's super generic it's beyond
generic in the first act I thought okay
we might get a cool characters it's the
same way of how American assassins sort
of let me down in the sense of it starts
off in a way of oh this is interesting
it's gonna be like a character study of
this guy becoming a spy similar tropes
to American assassin this girl has no
prior military background she's in this
school for like a couple months it's
just like the best red sparrow they've
ever encountered it's not an overly
clever movie and it wants you to believe
that all these people are so amazing at
being spies and they could be anywhere
and do anything and never really bothers
to show you anybody being particularly
smart or anybody being a particularly
adept at much of any yeah thing that
comes with espionage so you're just kind
of left to go oh yeah they're telling us
they keep telling you every 10 minutes
that you're always one step ahead you
you you're just like me you're just
naturally great and we're supposed to go
with that I mean it's it's violent at
times when it's violent it's engaging
because it's violent but it's not cool
violence it's not sexy I think it's
really actually pretty insulting and the
way they handle
sexual assault in this movie I'm not an
expert I'm not a woman but I just I
don't see how if you think this movie
was empowering I would like to hear that
argument I don't think so call you make
fun of us and call social justice We're
warriors whatever I don't give a [ __ ]
you're whatever you're on the wrong side
of the coin then I'd rather be called
that if I'm gonna look at this movie and
go it's really insensitive in the way
they handle it yeah if you make your
sexpionage movie that that you know kind
of hinges on assault at some point God
at least flesh at the right waist
explore please try to make it in a way
where it's like it's showing you the
ugliness of sexual violence like try to
do that at least but they don't even try
to do that yeah diving in character I
believe the psychology and how [ __ ] up
and traumatic this all is but you don't
get any of that and part of what makes
these kinds of movies effective
especially when you're wondering who is
everybody really what side is everybody
on what's going on and here like part of
the relish of that is is getting inside
at least your protagonists mind it's
just an it's on say another movies like
mother or 10 for horses just suffering
the whole time
mother I actually really enjoyed this
movies just bland beyond belief
I even think it's kind of insulting to
Russians in a lot of ways yeah I mean I
know word hunting a good position with
them in the world perhaps but like yeah
this is every Russian in this movie
pursues a rapist bad person that's how
they portray like every Russian dude and
they spent only redeemable one that's
not her happens to be you know in line
with somebody else not not truly Russian
yeah but of course the American dude
it's like the only good deal like like
truly likeable person in this movie and
then you're sitting there going I've
seen so much ugliness from everything
else
how are you so kind of easygoing in
charming you should be somber like the
rest of us I know this is the kind of
movie that we would have to spoil a lot
in order to really give you the details
as examples for why we don't like this
film it's the kind of film where I'm
like I wouldn't mind doing like a watch
along one day and just going let's pause
it and let's talk about why this why
this sucks all right if you think you're
getting Black Widow the movie it's not
if you're thinking together getting a
better version of atomic blonde it's not
and so some ways I actually won't want a
atomic one we were at an event where the
director was gonna show up after the
credits were done rolling what time it
said red sparrow at the very end no one
clapped
there was one clap until suddenly
everyone was Lifeson are we gonna clap
along the way you and everyone do the
movie yeah it was very much a polite
collab like when you go to a premiere of
a short film and everybody that's also
not like outwardly shitty it's not like
an incompetent movie it's just sort of
middling in a really frustrating way
it's not entertaining bad so all in all
guys we would say there are definitely
more reasons not to see this movie then
there are reasons to see this film yeah
save yourself some money
gotcha Jumanji yeah or watch mother
alright guys well that's our discussion
on red Sparrow I feel like we could have
said more in detail they like
it's part of the film this I feel like
you guys get the point you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up and check
us out on patreon yeah pull like music
video reactions and TV show reactions
including some animes like my hero
academia attack on Titan I'm covering
Jon's covering Riverdale Runaways right
now and we also do black lightning
together I was to cover the flash some
of those probably more we're gonna add
to the plate soon so go check us out on
patreon and weekly Q&A is over there to
love to have you